my name is you Rita Deza I come from
Washington of course I'm from Ethiopia
by way of Washington DC I come here to
participate in the world economic forum
but in my capacity as an advisor to the
Deputy Prime Minister of Ethiopia and
foreign minister I'm here to participate
and understand what it is that the world
is discussing when it comes to focusing
on Africa particularly this forum is put
together with regard to Africa and South
Africa focused one of the sectors that I
would like to further expand throughout
the continent in order to transform our
economies is the financial sector the
financial sector needs to be transformed
in such a way that transactions are
facilitated between companies and people
and the trade and commerce so that
business is promoted in such a way to
for a a purpose of fast bro for example
today most of our financial transactions
go through most of European banks one of
the area that most of African countries
need to focus on both the private sector
in some cases supported by the
government full partnership with the
private sector is really strengthening
our banking system our financial
transactions by developing the banking
sector of course along with it is the
technological transformation that comes
from of course my life from the overseas
developed nations but one thing that
Africa is enjoying more than any other
time
is a lot of qualified skilled labor
particularly in the technology sector
more and more the youth of Africa and
thanks to all universities a lot of
people are getting into that sector so I
would like to see as an African to our
banking system our infrastructure in the
financial transaction sector grow and
develop and expand that's the only way
we can transform our economy